&gt;&gt; Oh, it looks like they're almost ready to start the first hearing event. Susan,
what's going on, on the floor?
&gt;&gt; Well, people are just about ready to start the first hearing event.
&gt;&gt; And what property of hearing will this event be addressing?
&gt;&gt; This event will test our senseletes' ability to hear different pitches.
&gt;&gt; Susan, can you explain a little more about what that means?
&gt;&gt; Well, Andy, most humans can hear frequencies of 20,000 hertz. Any higher and we
simply can't hear that. So, this is going to be an absolute threshold test,
which means we're going to see just how high of a pitch these contestants can
hear.
&gt;&gt; And how are they going to be measuring that?
&gt;&gt; As you can see, our contestants are blind-folded and they're going to sit
around these speakers. Every now and then, a tone is going to play and if a
contestant hears a tone they raise their hand. If they raise their hand
incorrectly or don't hear it, they will be eliminated. The pitch will get
higher and higher until there is only one contestant left. Oh, it looks like
the ref is signaling for me to leave. It looks like they're ready to start.